he's a hall of famer he works for the
mlb network he's
on the call for the angels and the a's
on mlb network at 3
30 eastern today he's john smoltz back
with the program
john pretty eventful monday here
considering
the yankees in phillies has been
postponed the marlins can't fly home
from philadelphia they got 14 members of
the organization who've tested positive
and we don't know about the phillies
anybody who came in contact with them
other than that how's your monday
yeah uh this is uh not it's not
obviously the news you want to have
when a baseball season is getting ready
to be one of the most exciting seasons
ever
uh i know going into this baseball had
so many different protocols and
scenarios that if things came up they
had
the luxury of moving a team out of a hot
spot or so on
you know you just hope that the certain
trends that have happened the last
couple of weeks
guys seem to be getting over it really
quickly and
there hasn't been any real setbacks
there but when you have a high number in
one team that is a concern i'm gonna
remain optimistic because i think if
everybody keeps pulling in the right
direction and
and adheres to the protocols maybe this
is just
a little bit of a blip but it's
certainly it's certainly a number
that no franchise or team wants to have
happen at any point in the season yet
alone really early
but i'm wondering john at one point
these are you know games that are
postponed
but at what point do they become
forfeits because we only have we have a
finite number of
days and we know we have 60 games to get
those games in
i don't know how much wiggle room is
there for major league baseball
to extend the regular season as far as
dates go
yeah i mean it is a it's a tough um
it's a quandary right i mean if this was
multiple teams i think the the answer
would be a lot easier
it's it's right now one team um
and i don't think that unless it just
continues to
uh be more of an issue i think the the
best way to address it
is is to move on in in a cautious way
and let your roster
you know pick up the pieces until those
guys can get cleared
and that's going to be an interesting
next couple days to see what you just
said if the other teams
don't have any traces of this and and my
hope is that
that it is an isolated and and and
one-off scenario i hate it for the
marlins
i hate it for anyone that's got to go
through it but hopefully it's a quick
one and hopefully it's one of those
scenarios where people
talk about already that have been
asymptomatic
have had no real issues and have come
back pretty quickly
i don't know if it's a coincidence or
not but former cy young winners
didn't have a good weekend now you
already have david price and felix
hernandez who aren't even pitching this
season
clayton kershaw tweaks his back corey
kluber and justin verlander
looks like they're head to the entry
list
just the whole process here of these
starting pitchers trying to
you guys are creatures a habit and you
know to try to hit the ground running
no real spring training here or you had
one and interrupted by
four months i mean is is this alarming
to you with what you're seeing
with uh some of these marquee pictures
john yeah uh you know i hope not
and because here's here's what would be
my battle cry if i was still playing and
talking to my team i i would say this
look
we can't be paralyzed by the what-if
scenarios we've got to do the best we
can to be in shape i'm really
actually pleasantly surprised by the
shape
everybody's in and really how everybody
has been
as if they haven't missed any time
you're always going to have see here's
the problem
every normal year there's going to be
injuries matter of fact
i've said this forever baseball's never
addressed really the entry
epidemic that has happened because
there's so many pieces and so many
people
who pick up there's so many talented
players so when you have this scenario
and and it's going to be magnified
everyone's going to watch for everything
i think the natural
thing to do is say well it's because of
this the teams that bond together and
the teams that overcome whatever
it is about being this year being
uncomfortable i honestly think
are are going to have a huge advantage
even if their roster isn't the best
roster going into the season so
i i think everyone's got a watchful eye
for everything that pops up
and i want to i want to believe that
this is just an isolated incident
unfortunately and maybe not as bad as
first reported
and then shohei ohtani who hadn't been
on the mound for 20 months he goes out
don't even
register and out coming back from tommy
john's surgery
yeah that one was that's more to do with
with having pits having not pitched in a
long time right i think
having gone through tommy john's surgery
and coming back in 11 months
uh i wasn't quite where i needed to be
after four games
i think he's going to be fine because
he's had a lot of time of rest but
there's a lot of rust
and here's the one thing he could do
that no other pitcher can do
he can make up for that lackluster
performance with a couple home runs the
next time he gets to the plate
he can take it out on the baseball this
is a special kid
and uh you know i just think that
that the only problem he's going to have
is waiting six more days to get back on
the mound
uh he just didn't let the ball go and
it's natural you tell yourself to let it
go the ball came out cutting
these are all byproducts to coming back
from tommy john that
after you get reps you'll be fine
any surprises so far anything stand out
yeah the biggest thing i i really can't
wait to watch
is the limited games give these teams
that may not be able to
sustain the pitching over 162. i i think
the easy pick
that everybody was talking about could
be a surprise san diego padres
they have a tremendous bullpen they've
got young pitching that may or may not
have been able to
sustain itself over 162. i just think
this bodes well for what i've always
tried to tell you i'm an i'm an advocate
for and that's the split seasons
that gives everybody a little [ __ ] a
little race
to have a competitive chance and and i
hope we can go without any more hiccups
because you're going to talk about this
year at the end
of of baseball and you'll remember this
year for a lot of things
and hopefully it's because it's the most
exciting 60 games you've ever seen
he's john smoltz the hall of famer major
league baseball network analyst angels
a's on mlb network at 3 30 eastern
the smallest crowd you ever pitched in
front of was
easily atlanta braves first three years
probably 570 people
i tried counting them when i was on the
mound so that tells you i wasn't really
locked into the game
i heard the vendors i heard the lights
buzzing i heard everybody ragging me
uh it was a very difficult time the
first couple years
putting on a braves uniform everyone
talked about
i'll never forget you know showing up
excited about being in the big leagues
i went to a local comedy club and the
first 45 minutes was on the atlanta
breaks
and i mean people were falling out of
their seats laughing i had to get out
and they just always used to say this
would be a great year to paint the seats
uh because nobody was there so it is
distracting my first three years
in the big leagues i couldn't do what
they're doing right now it would take
so much adjustment for me and i learned
how to
lock in and and challenge myself in
games that
maybe you found yourself drifting that's
the biggest challenge for a lot of guys
is their personalities may not fit for
this
like a guy who plays with emotion and by
the seat of his pants is going to have
to recreate that that's hard for him
but the guy like a a kluber or someone
who's just
laid back this is no big deal like this
would be a great environment i think
personalities have a lot to do with how
guys will
deal with this in this atmosphere well
you also have that downtime like what do
you do
in today's world major league baseball
as opposed
i mean back there in atlanta you at
least had atlanta but
these guys have to really self-police
themselves yeah that that is exactly
right and that goes back to where i
would have that team meeting and just
encourage guys
that whatever creativity we could come
up with on our time away
um adhering to the protocols that would
be the challenge and that's the teams
that do that are going to be the teams
that have the most
advantage of getting through this
because what you don't want in a long
season a long journey you get teams that
drift and players that drift
you don't want that if three weeks out
like it's real easy to to have your
season going the wrong way
because you don't have much time for
your statistical categories
and or have a bad week go two and eight
as a team and you start feeling like
you know you just threw your season away
that's going to be the challenge for
managers
more so than information more so than
strategy
and that's what's going to make this
kind of unique you just hope people
and players do what they got to do it's
a shorter time
and shoot the trade deadlines in five
weeks so
there's a lot of things that uh are sped
up i saw where you played golf
in tahoe with clemens and maddox yeah
um if you were going to build the
perfect pitcher out of u3 so you could
take whatever you wanted from each one
what do you take from clemens well
just you know i i would take clemens and
maddox and morph them into one because
it's the ultimate control power scenario
i mean
that would be the machine that would be
tough to ever be
you've got the power of clemens the
purse precision of of
maddox and and you yeah what would you
start your franchise with i'll give you
maddox or clemens
wow oh man in today's
baseball well you know what that's a
great question that everyone says well
you know greg maddox would would be
exposed or glad would be exposed today
i totally disagree i think maddox would
be the same pitcher
and have more strikeouts because his
ability to hit spots where a guy's
trying to swing
you gotta understand errors are
difficult to
to compare because everybody today is
swinging with a launch angle angle and
he's going to get the ball
under the barrel the bat as easily as
anybody else
and so everything's going to be kind of
um
yeah he may give up a few more home runs
but his ability to miss bats
that's my one argument i would make that
argument and the st louis cardinals back
in the day
when they used to not hit home runs and
run would still
have success because it would be so
difficult to defend them and so
difficult
to try to lock in on maddox because this
ball moves so much i just wonder john at
some point
do we have somebody who it's it's
counterintuitive that they decide that
they're going to play small ball
that that the ballpark is a pitchers
ball park and we're going to have
guys who run and just it'll be different
you'll save money too you don't have to
spend money on home run hitters here but
and you're playing
80 81 games at home
so that is a true home field advantage i
don't know i just i wonder if somebody
goes
the heck with just hitting home runs
we're going to play a different style of
baseball
i i totally agree and you're going to
get some teams actually doing that i
know kansas city talked about in their
rebuild to try and get back to a little
bit of that they play in a big ballpark
you know you think the one thing that
nobody really you wouldn't think
colorado would go to that because
obviously that's a masters park but
think how big that park
is and if you had speed you put more
pressure on the teams i totally agree
with you i think
it's taken a while for teams to do that
but you're going to find that the
teams are going to have to zig a little
bit when everyone's zagging
and and i'm looking forward to because
that adjustment would be for a lot of
teams they would look at it we just
don't showcase enough of the guys talent
at times there's guys that can
run there's weapons that we kind of hold
in and
and because of analytics at times don't
allow those uh packages to be unwrapped
when's the one time when you gave up a
home run and you just went
that guy took me deep i'm embarrassed
oh my gosh um there's i'm infamous for
the jose lean not hitting a home run in
2500 at bats
i gave him up i i gave one up to him
like
um every time i see vince coleman he's
like
i can't believe you threw that slider
down and he hadn't hit a home run in a
thousand at bats and i gave one it was
it was a chucky car like i could go on
and on for the guys that i
didn't think could hit a home run and i
did them the absolutely like did them
the
biggest favor they could do well you hit
their bat i think it's good
i think so like like there's no shame in
giving up a home run to bonds
no not at all no i mean that that's
that's that's part of the game and you
know
those guys are going to hit like fuzz
pitching today there's no doubt i would
be on the leaderboard
for some of the farthest given there's
no doubt and i would have no problem
with that it's the wall scrapers it's
the ones that you're just kind of open
but i did i there were times where i
i sat on the mountain go really like i
just did that so
guys that got their um first hits off of
me a lot like career i threw more balls
back to the dugout for career first hits
and that that that was starting to
become a running joke in the team but
yeah
those things uh i remember though you're
starting to sound like a modern-day bob
euchre but you're a hall of famer
euchre's a hall of fame announcer here
well
those are the things that stick out you
know more than ever you don't know this
guy
my favorite story is is like i chipper
and i played for a hundred years
and and one of the things i i would
always do every time you know he was hit
this
unbelievable mind for recognizing and
remembering especially when he was at
the plate
and juan castro was playing for the
dodgers it was out in l.a
and i had no clue about this guy and i
didn't know what what what he could do
so i called him over
and uh i said hey what do i do you know
what's this guy like he goes
ah he's a slap hitter just go after him
with a fastball
first pitch line drive off my wrist into
center field fractured my wrist
i had to come out of the gate and i said
don't worry about ever coming over to
the mount again
it was the way i just couldn't believe
it he said well i didn't tell you to
throw it right down the middle
and you probably and you guys are so
crazy that you probably remember
like counts that you know you'll go oh
it's a 3-1
like vince coleman hit a home run off of
you do you remember the count
you said it was a slider down yeah i had
two strikes on him
of course you know a bunch of fastballs
and he said you there he goes there's no
chance i was catching
up to your fastball and you threw me a
down and in slider and i just kind of
scooped it so yeah
oh god i love the memory you you can't
remember if your wife tells you to get
something at the grocery store
correct but you can tell me the count
when bonds hit the incredible home run
off of you that you still can't believe
it
yep that that's uh i wish i had that
that kind of
capacity in school to remember remember
things like that
uh have fun today john hope you're well
and uh thanks for joining us
all right hope everyone stays safe
that's john smalls hall of famer mlb
network analyst
angels a's on mlb network at 3 30
eastern